hey guys Ryan Wright is here hey guys
Lauren guys here Lauren is finally back
a lot of requests and I brought her here
because she has a beautiful smile hey
this is the perfect transition for us
whoa
we're gonna watch the video that [ __ ]
ton of people have been telling major
watch for months okay
called smile smile do you see what he
did there see how he tied that Ameri oh
it's like in a neat little bow that's
what good riders yeah Lauren why waste
any more time let's watch this [ __ ]
let's do it doesn't this sound said he
extorts yeah makes Veronica very
uncomfortable yeah I'm coming yeah and I
came okay I'm playing a lot too much
with this joke about myself the
following content may cause smiles tears
face drinks need to know too
for some reason
me
you
[ __ ] watch no idea
she provides
it's
Oh
so to me
to be me
I guess
you're smiling now
okay that was weird
the [ __ ] was that that's super weird
that was nothing why did so many of you
suggest that I don't get what's so loved
about it I mean it's weird sure I mean
it did make me smile a few times it's
kind of smiling a lot just because I'm
how weird it was oh so it's a parody of
My Little Ponies they got the song smile
is obviously from like a My Little Pony
episode probably and I guess he like
animated this other cartoon along to
this now this song Malvo
you know everything Muslim it smile song
so the plot of this is someone who just
loves to go around beating other
creatures and then someone stands up and
right but those are all ponies from the
My Little Pony cartoon okay I was
familiar with My Little Pony this
probably would have been a more
interesting video for Mamie I mean I've
seen it like twice and I recognize all
the characters and obviously in My
Little Pony they're all like friendly
and whatever yeah but so that was weird
okay so they're just making fun of the
fact of how friendly and polite I mean
youyou remember My Little Ponies
remember little right no I don't I mean
I mean I was really a girl thing but I
had the little My Little Pony it
probably loves a girl oh yeah I know
you're talking about like they've
created a cartoon that is on now and
it's actually they've gotten this really
weird cult following from guys like your
age called bronies I don't know it's
super weird yeah so My Little Ponies is
a big thing right now or was like when
it came back so maybe that's why people
like this
bronies out there you'll dig in there I
don't know how to talk about this video
to be honest really I ain't I'm not sure
what responses you're looking for this
is not the type of things that I would
seek out - what yeah a lot of these
YouTube videos that people recommend are
just like weird music
backed up well I don't like chocolate
video though oh they need the gig to
give me the metal song that a Japanese
band that was weird to you guys you guys
are recommending the weirdest viral
videos yeah every viral video I've seen
that's like a cartoon is like incredibly
violent something's wrong with you
subscribers something's seriously wrong
with these subscribers well if you guys
are new to the channel you can subscribe
the real rejects yay where is it button
yeah and Lauren has a channel too
yeah Lauren got channel fullscreen just
partnered with them gave me a few
suggestions yeah yeah so here's a
playlist of all the trailer reactions
yeah this is it over there yeah I'm
putting it somewhere here I don't ask
you something on this side
Oh another video oh you could check out
another vine like how they do that there
see they're like look at those videos
yeah exactly how they do okay so like
we'll have a beginning to know Lauren
God oh that's my favorite row back row
back doesn't allowing Taylor yeah the
subscribe they say you shouldn't just
say subscribe you should like make it
fun and interesting so if you wanna you
know just get updated every time any
videos out click this I button this is
fun an interesting right here fullscreen
thanks man Thank You fullscreen I'm glad
you guys are partnering with me and I'm
sure you guys are really happy to put
this Agreement all right nolo okay
sorry I had to every video you just
clown on every video that is your like
go to maneuvers just one without a J
don't lose 15 shoutout maybe no okay huh
oh I thought you said something
AJ don't lose 15 this must be a 15 year
old kid who is named AJ yeah except that
if he was 15 years old then he would
have to change his username every time
every got all that time every time I
can't wait till he's 69 maybe 15 is his
er number why what was 15 symbol s I
don't know ask him AJ are you black or
maybe it's like don't lose 15 pounds
your name doesn't make sense I don't
know how to give you a shout-out and I
am sorry but I mention you so that
counts
oh yeah someone sent over your black I
want to know if you're black I knew a
black guy named a Jew I know a guy named
AJ uh-oh
sounds interesting is a black either
fair enough
Marcelo pre Colo first baby please I
need a shout out more cell Oprah :
that's the name of an Italian dish first
what second no he was saying first as he
was the first one to click on my video
uh yeah so good for you why don't you
know eyes that say babe I hate you know
how much I hate when people say please
pls you know how much I hate oh I know
God boy your biggest things at how hard
is it to just write out please
Marcelo you've pissed off Lauren
congratulations plus it's not a word
neither's be nude Gy can you just put
the egg right that's only one letter
okay please you cut out e ie 3 and E but
the baby like I'm just who I wanna do
come on back that's okay Lauren that's
okay yeah I'm okay Wow
thank God I did some yes and improv
aboard on that one that's great but yeah
Marcelo good for you for Colo that can
be
your penis if it's prickly prick coal
whatever Lord don't be a weird name look
at your penis let's not do this Lord did
you name your penis
what's your penis isn't he the Paul Rudd
why is it the Paul Rudd because um it
just it looks like Paul Rudd it looks a
lot like Paul Rudd it just it's really
sarcastic penis dude I'm very sarcastic
incredibly charming Jesus Perez hey Ryan
maybe his name is hey Zeus no I'm pretty
sure it's Jesus I've never had a
shout-out before maybe I could get one
Jesus Perez he is Jesus okay hey soos
will go with hey soos how do you know
that's hazy
don't [ __ ] do this right now I think
you for you to name your kid hey soos
you should just call him Jesus anyway
why because it's like that's what
they're going for they want our kid to
be blessed no this is like not how they
would see it in their language
whoo what whoa who's they Hispanic
people you don't know that no I don't
know that hey soos Perez that's what he
sounds like
huh spot on spot on it is exactly how
he's a Samana I'm not racist
and I don't stereotype but that is how
you sound a soos man it's Jesus Perez me
all right take care hey sis